[Musik]
ich bin eine Art Düsenantrieb bauen und
mit Ski den Berg auch wieder bergauf
hochfahren zu können aber hauptsächlich
um auch auf dem Feld nebenan Folge als
rumbrettern zu können auf gerade Ebene
ohne Skipiste
dieses Video wird unterstützt von insta
360 mehr dazu später ich bin ja eher
kein Fan von fossilen Brennstoffen darum
setzen wir auf Elektromobilität und
nehmen sogenannte edfs das sind im
Grunde ziemlich krasse Propeller in
einem aerodynamischen Gehäuse die an
ziemlich krasse Motoren gesteckt werden
vielleicht kennt ihr die vom Youtuber
Jay Laser der hat sich ein paar davon
auf dem Rücken geschnallt und ist damit
einfach geflogen also wir wollen ja
damit Skifahren ne jetzt ist meine Frage
wie kriegen wir das jetzt hin das ist
bei uns nicht zum brennen anfängt
müssen wir da einfach nur ganz
vertikabel nehmen und halt Sicherung
einbauen für die Sicherheit ist also
gesorgt dachten wir zumindest denn bei
diesem Projekt ist Technik für ganze
zweieinhalb Tausend Euro abgeraubt aber
mehr dazu später an diesem Punkt im
Video warten wir nämlich immer noch
genau auf die Lieferung von dieser
Technik diese Turbinen die wir bestellt
haben soll nämlich links und rechts an
eine Eisenstange montiert werden die man
dann in der Hand hält und bevor wir
weiter planen können brauchen wir die
Turbinen um sie auszumessen ja
Alter okay die sind einfach angekommen 3
Sekunden nachdem wir angefangen
und kurz darauf kam auch die Motoren an
also ursprünglich hatten wir vorher
diese fetten Motoren die kommen mit
übertrieben sind mit 50.000 Umdrehungen
pro Minute da jetzt rein zu machen und
dann mit dieser richtig geilen Turbine
hier richtig fett zu erzeugen Problem
passt nicht rein wir haben jetzt alles
Reserve noch diese Motoren die ungefähr
nur 60% der Power haben die passen da
kommen wir locker rein aber die haben
halt nur auf 60% der Power ist natürlich
wir machen das einfach selber und zwar
so dass die dicken Motoren halt dann
doch reinpassen übrigens 150 € pro Stück
kostet das heißt Pascal können sich der
Motor halt mit Fernbedienung dreht und
so weiter und so fort diesen coolen
Griff und ich konzentriere das Teil hier
komplett neu damit das 3D drucken können
so hier Druck jetzt zu wie eine 1 und
hier
zwei aber die beiden sind nur der Plan B
Plan A ist Turbine 3 im kunstharzdrucker
weil die höhere Temperaturen aushalten
und schöner aussehen wird und so wird
die Turbine jetzt Schicht für Schicht
gedruckt hier sieht man hoffentlich wie
lange ich am 3D Modell der komplexen
turbinengehäuseformen gesessen bin der
Druck dauert jetzt ganze 14 Stunden also
schaue ich mal bei Pascal vorbei denn
zwischen testweise schon einen kleinen
Motor zum Laufen gebracht hat der in das
gekaufte Gehäuse reinpasst den Kollegen
machen hier
er ist total geil weil man kann es
einfach per App steuern und dann geht
das Teil an das sind jetzt übrigens
gerade 7% der Leistung gewesen
auf jeden Fall
stehen dann würde ich mich auf jeden
Fall locker ziehen
[Musik]
okay das ist ungefähr 20% von dem was
die großen Motoren dann können und nach
14 Stunden ist das Gehäuse für diese
größeren Motoren auch fertig
das ist Beifahrer unser größter Esser
ab ins Waschbecken
[Musik]
Problem ist jetzt wenn ich den hier rein
macht und der Motor dann gut heiß wird
dann wird dieses Plastik hier extrem
weich deswegen habe ich die
Holzplättchen konzentriert die man
dazwischen liegt aber damit es ein
bisschen isoliert ist so und damit ist
der Motor hier fest eingelassen und dann
kommt jetzt auch schon diese absolut
Geisteskranke Turbine da drauf
so dann kommt die Nase da drauf auf die
Nase die Schraube und dann ist die erste
Turbine fertig und es sieht absolut geil
aus
[Musik]
bombenfest da passiert nichts das ist
richtig geil jetzt kommt noch ein
zweiter hier rechts dran und dann ist
unsere Gerätschaft auch schon bald
fertig wir machen sehr sehr Anprobe
einmal hier rein sind und Zweck von soll
nämlich sein dass man hier jetzt wieder
reinhängt und dann kommt
von dem Teil gezogen ohne dass ich so
viel Kraft aufwenden muss und natürlich
auch wenn es irgendwie ein Eigenleben
entwickeln
sondern normal nehme hat man so richtig
geile first person Sicht wie ich da halt
im Schnitt ist und natürlich aber auch
von allen anderen Richtungen
gemacht habe
Studio 22
Perspektive und wenn ich jetzt einfach
die andere Seite finden will einfach
umdrehen war super geil wird ich kann
damit aber sogar noch richtig gut raus
tun und einfach meinen ganzen Körper
Filmen mal kurz auf mein Gesicht
und schon habe ich eine geile Aufnahme
und mit dem deep Track dass ich hier
gerade anwende hätte ich mir das Ganze
Track noch einmal sparen können geht
automatisch man sieht da natürlich auch
noch viel besser aus als das was ich mal
neu gemacht habe das sieht ja anders aus
es wird immer eine Drohne einfach direkt
vor mir schweben das Thema Film auf der
Piste ist dann auf jeden Fall abgehakt
also Pascal der verrückt ja der Zeug
morgen das Ding kommen wir fertig
gemacht und noch mal das andere auch
verkabel jetzt gehen beide
[Applaus]
das ist komplett geil das hat so ein
bisschen was von MOTORRAD
ich will jetzt mal probieren 80 % Power
ist es gerade okay let's go
also das geht schon gut also Skifahren
sollte damit überhaupt keinen Stress
sein ach stimmt hier ist auch ein fettes
Display hier oben steht wie viel warte
hier gerade draußen
7000 Watt das wir schauen dass die
Motoren und sich abbrennen weil wie
Eingang zum Video gesagt haben wir aber
gar keinen Bock
[Musik]
drauf komplett geil ich finde die beiden
Tobi sind auch richtig schön geworden
Alter 3D war richtig gut gemacht ich bin
auch der Griff Manu und der Stelle
richtig geil geworden und die Elektronik
natürlich auch über den Zellen ja okay
dann würde ich glaube ich das auch gar
nicht mehr weiter die batteriesten ich
würde dann halt auch sagen Abfahrt
einfach so wir suchen jetzt nach
Location wo wir Skifahren können wir
auch schon was im Auge nur wird es ein
bisschen schwierig weil man weiß nicht
ob das wirklich über Schnee liegt wie
die Gegebenheiten sind wir wollen jetzt
auch nicht irgendwo sein wo viel los ist
weil die Dinger echt laut sind stören
bis dahin werde ich auf jeden Fall mit
der Insel X3 ein paar geile Aufnahmen
machen
[Musik]
und im Skigebiet angekommen suchen wir
jetzt nach der idealen Fahrbahn auf der
wir unsere Chats testen können ohne
direkt von anderen wegen dem lernverlag
zu werden
[Musik]
so werden wir jetzt eine perfekte Stelle
gefunden das ist hier ein Weg oder eine
Straße wo auch quasi irgendeinen
forstwirtschaftsfahrzeug fährt das heißt
hier ist eigentlich voll gut zum
Skifahren und jetzt fahren auch gar
nichts los und es sieht auch so geil aus
was hat übel weh das war die
Gehirnerschütterung wert
also ganz blöde Nummer wir sind jetzt
seit zwei Stunden hergefahren haben das
perfekte Skigebiet gefunden endlich
Schnee überall richtig geiler Schnee
aber wir haben mal die Technik vergessen
die im Rucksack war mit der wir halt
dann das Ding betreiben das heißt wir
sind umsonst gekommen
vielleicht ist das ja ein Zeichen weil
eigentlich haben wir den Chat Griff ja
gebaut um auch ohne Skipiste Skifahren
zu können so für ready und wie ist das
Wetter will liegt mittlerweile zu Hause
in Bayern auch ordentlich Schnee auf dem
Feldweg nebenan aber nach einigen Test
lässt uns diesmal die Technik im Stich
wir wissen nicht genau wie aber auf
jeden Fall haben wir die 1250 € teuren
Motorcontroller geschrottet aber dank
Sponsoren wie insta 360 konnte ich die
einfach direkt noch mal bestellen und
Pascal das ganze damit reparieren
es geht jetzt hoffen wir dass er den
nicht auch noch schrotten
und dann habe ich die 1200 Euro Dinger
weißt du schön war direkt noch mal in
die Luft gejagt weil ich ein Stecker
falsch rum angesteckt habe so weil ich
jetzt einmal vier von diesen Dingern
scheinbar geschrottet habe und wir das
halt aber noch vor Weihnachten zum
laufen bringen wollen bin ich jetzt hier
bei Voltaik in der Nähe von Würzburg
wenn ihr Erfahrung beim Entwickeln und
Prototyping von E-Mobility habt meldet
euch gerne mal bei Voltaik auf insta die
suchen nämlich nach Mitstreitern
[Musik]
und der gute franz hat mir geholfen und
aber auch noch mal
zwei weitere verkauft das ist echt teuer
das Zeug aber okay zwei weitere verkauft
und mit denen wir das hoffentlich
funktionieren und weil Pascal heute noch
im Urlaub ist das ziemlich geil dass er
mir sogar dabei hilft das denn jetzt
zusammen zu stecken deswegen haben wir
jetzt da noch von dem prototype ein
dickes Stück Alu und dann machen wir
jetzt einen das auf die eine einen Vesco
auf die andere Seite und das reduziert
die Feuer gefahren und dann bleibt es
kühl
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier so vier Stück verlötet wenn ich
nicht mal einfüllt hätte
[Musik]
kurz vor der Wand gefallen ja aber mega
geil ja was ein bisschen danke schön und
damit geht's wieder drei Stunden zurück
nach München wir sind jetzt hier es
läuft jetzt alles und jetzt muss ich nur
noch einstellen und dann kann ich
endlich loslegen dieser wird zum ersten
Mal alles einmal in den Rucksack gepackt
dann ist hier einmal das Gaspedal die
Motoren sind angesteckt so wie sie
gehören jetzt die Batterien erst dünn
dann dick also so sieht man das jetzt an
ich habe einen Rucksack ja komm hinten
rum das Kabel wird drüber okay wir
probieren
[Musik]
es geht es geht es bewegt sich endlich
irgendwas oh mein Gott und auch mal
[Musik]
es ist so krass das ist eigentlich
funktioniert es hat so lange gedauert
und ich brenne noch nicht es ist noch
nicht explodiert zack erstmal alles
abnehmen
die wasserdicht so und dann ist der App
kann ich mir das dann direkt anschauen
geil
mega geil so nun das Bild ist aber auf
mir zu stabilisieren checkt dir das
automatisch du verfolgt mich automatisch
auch wenn ich irgendwie bewegen Kurve
bin und so sieht das dann aus und wenn
ich jetzt auf Export geht kann ich aber
Teilen egal ob Instagram Facebook oder
Whatsapp oder YouTube
60 x 3 einfach mit meinem Handy
verbunden sichere Filme jetzt gerade
kann ich 360 Grad kann man auch einfach
drehen und kann die auch dann auch noch
starten drücken und jetzt lege ich das
mal in die Handyhalterung rein die wir
extra gemacht haben und schneide das mal
zu auch crazy weil hier ist halt einfach
diese Stange an der die extra befestigt
ist aber man sieht die halt einfach auf
überhaupt gar nicht also das ist einfach
die Kamera in der Luft schweben ich
finde ich habe beim Anziehen
mittlerweile tatsächlich auch ziemlich
smooth man stellt erst den hier so auf
dann mache ich hier das eine drüber dann
lege ich mir hier dieses fette Kabel
einmal rum dann kann ich mich auch
hinstellen
verzichten dran ja und so bin ich ready
to go
und
T's go
[Musik]
also wenn man Vollgas gibt kann man
bergauf fahren aber das ist nicht so
geil geil das ist wirklich einfach auf
einer ebenen schnell zu fahren ich meine
wer kennt das Problem nicht jetzt hat
nicht jeder eine Piste ohne krassen
berggeber da gar nichts aber
[Musik]
meisten Spaß macht natürlich einfach
bergab fahren und Vollgas
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie ihr seht hat die Instagram
gemacht also checkt sie mal über den
Link in der Videobeschreibung aus manu
hat zwar extrem geile Shots gefilmt mit
der normalen Kamera aber sowas hier kann
nur eine 360° Kamera und das sogar wenn
man keinen Kameramann hat einfach geil
einfach geil dein Horizon Block ist der
Horizont immer horizontal egal wie will
sich die Kamera bei eurem Abenteuer
dreht und im remote ist man selbst immer
im Fokus auch ohne Nachbearbeitung
technisch gesehen eine extreme
Bereicherung auch für unsere zukünftigen
Videos und bestimmt auch für eure weil
sie herkömmliche actioncams und in
manchen Situationen sogar Drohnen fast
überflüssig macht alle Infos in der
Infobox und ich bin damit raus